all right Ben Affleck right like to me  because in Mariah they can say that he  likes right yeah and Ben likes you right  in us I would love to live in a society  where I can go you know what let's try  I'll just have dinner right but I  wouldn't do it why not why because I'm  not gay dog okay  but yo dog I love [ __ ] dog it would  just be so valid I would to get uh to  know that Ben would want to [ __ ] you yes  okay like that's so much currency right  there I don't know but you [ __ ] okay  go out with him okay I want to say  something in today's society  no but in an alternative Universe yes  let me tell you something if Ben Affleck  left JLo for you  like I could be happy I would be  instantly happy would I be instantly  famous  I'd be instantly famous guy in the most  the most famous person that has ever  been